Various Insect Snacks.
Algeria's Locusts.
The natives ate desert locusts which were cooked in salt water and dried in the sun.
Australia's Bogong.
Aborigines love to feast on highly nutritious Bogong moths...
...which taste like walnuts or pecans.
Moths are also ground into paste and made into cakes.
Witchety grubs live in the roots of the acacia bush and when cooked taste like almonds.
For dessert, aborigines dug into the ground looking for the nests of honeypot ants...
...and are eaten like candy.
Bali's Dragonfly. Dragonfly and damselfly adults are hunted in Bali.
They are grilled over charcoal...
...or boiled with ginger, garlic, shallots, chili pepper and coconut milk.
Korea's Moth Pupae.
Some Koreans also enjoy silk moth pupae...
...and it is a popular snack for children at amusement areas.
Nigeria Kwara State's Termites.
People from this area have been known to feast on termites,...
...crickets, grasshoppers, caterpillars.
The ten-centimeter-long and more than five-centimeter-wide palm weevil larva...
...is fleshy and grublike with a high fat content.
They are delicious when fried.
Thailand's Grasshoppers.
Full-grown grasshoppers or locusts are deep-fried like French fries...
...and enjoyed by many at traditional markets.